this is a full circle moment for me I
was in New York for the season one
junket and here we are for season four
all right and now we're talking about
the last season from the first to the
last yeah
I do know something about the two of you
when you're doing press together you put
in Little Words that you hide or you
play a game what are we doing today
what's the secret word what's the game
Preposterous as an accusation well no
we're actually we're doing a different
thing this time we're doing you can't
tell the voice yeah no we no we've got
no games
oh yeah uh Nell's mirroring my uh body
language which is quite difficult
because he talks a lot with his hands
and I'm sorry yes you do and I'm sort of
forgetting my own answers to my
questions
okay so I'm going to keep my eye out for
this interview I'm gonna make sure
Rupert you gotta just like move your
hands like crazy
there you go
um Rupert over the summer you had as a
cast dinner with night to celebrate his
birthday and his and your daughter
Wednesday gave him a card that she
colored and she calls him good night as
his nickname I'm curious after working
with him for so long do you two have
nicknames
food night yes oh for nine
oh nice yeah we do do we yeah yeah we'd
call him Dad no no we would be like our
Dad's on set because he like was our
sort of overseer yeah and everything
paternal figure from behaved dad's
coming to him
so yeah I mean that's quite a lot of us
would actually call him dad Toby
actually started that not not Daddy
maybe you would because
oh good job you guys no
you're not bad
sorry now when you say goodbye to a show
a show that has an ensemble cast has
locations has a house that you're
filming in constantly what is the
toughest part about saying goodbye to a
series like this for you
I'm really bad with goodbyes in general
like I just I'm really bad at it like I
can't watch the last episode of TV shows
full stop because I feel like then the
characters are still alive somewhere and
I don't have to say goodbye to them it's
like a weird John green thing that I do
um but I mean for this in particular I
sort of grew up on this show and I grew
up with these guys and
saying goodbye to Rupert Toby and Lauren
and it was just like really hard because
I truly love them very much so but um
you know I think we're stuck with each
other forever
but uh that was that was the hardest
part truly is just saying goodbye to the
people
and Rupert on your last day of filming I
need to know did you Nick anything from
set did you take any crafts any costumes
baby Jericho yeah I wish I I'm so bad at
that
um I know I mean and it's very hard to
do it because
you have to be quite sneaky I do have we
have like a family ring I kept that
and some I kept some pajamas it takes
like Jimmy has a lot of pajamas yeah
I took all of Leanne's clothes yeah yeah
sounds like a good outfit to wear every
day
now
now if you were to have any member of
this cast be your personal servant for
the day Toby
Toby yeah it would be so fun to boss him
around Anakin cook he can cook like 100
Toby would be hilarious he'd get so
angry as well
and Rupert who would you ask
yeah totally I can't really taste Toby
really he's the perfect choice it's just
fantastic yeah and he he's just very
he can just do he can just do do stuff
it would just be really comical it would
just be really funny he'd hate it he'd
absolutely hate it which is why it would
be funny
well thank you so much to the both of
you I can't wait to see how this ends I
only got three episodes so I'm dying to
know but all the best and look forward
to our next chat thank you so much that
was fun bye bye